Shure:  早上好
Shure: Good morning
Katrina: 早上好
Katrina: Good morning
Katrina: 在干什么啊
Katrina: What are you doing?
Shure:  这锅太次了
Shure: This pan is terrible
Shure:  我受不了了
Shure: I can't stand it
Shure:  这是不是啊
Shure: Is this it?
Shure:  这呢吗这不锅铲
Shure: Isn't this a spatula?
Katrina: 洗洁精在哪
Katrina: Where's the dish soap?
Shure:  他都快撞你脸上了都
Shure: It's almost hitting your face
Katrina: 洗洁精
Katrina: Dish soap
Katrina: 啊哈哈哈sorry
Katrina: Ahahaha, sorry
Shure:  擦一下擦
Shure: Wipe it up
Katrina: 要不直接洗碗吧
Katrina: How about we just wash the dishes?
Katrina: 反正手也弄脏了
Katrina: Since our hands are already dirty
Katrina: 啥呀鸡蛋吗
Katrina: What's that, an egg?
Katrina: 没事
Katrina: No worries
Shure:  是不油少了
Shure: Isn't there not enough oil?
Alice: 也不少吧
Alice: Not really
Shure:  对啊这有点吃油感觉
Shure: Yeah, it feels a bit oily
Shure:  哎呀妈我一会都不敢不敢煎了都
Shure: Oh man, I'm scared to fry it now
Shure:  再倒点
Shure: Pour some more
Shure:  这锅有点粘的话就多倒点
Shure: If the pan is a bit sticky, just pour more
Shure:  还给你剩点
Shure: Save some for you
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Mm
Katrina: 什么呀那是肉吗
Katrina: What's that, is it meat?
Shure:  不是我说收拾一下
Shure: No, I mean clean up a bit
Katrina: 不是
Katrina: No
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh
Katrina: 我昨晚那个写写报告去
Katrina: I was writing that report last night
Katrina: 写到5点
Katrina: Wrote until 5
Katrina: 写到5点钟
Katrina: Wrote until 5 o'clock
Katrina: 然后刚醒
Katrina: Then just woke up
Katrina: 因为总感觉每天这小小段的时间
Katrina: Because I always feel that this little bit of time each day
Katrina: 写不好然后影响我的心情
Katrina: If I don't write well, it affects my mood
Katrina: 还不如通宵一晚上
Katrina: Might as well stay up all night
Katrina: 嗯嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm
Shure:  行了给它捞出来吧
Shure: Okay, take it out
Shure:  这肯定熟了
Shure: It's definitely cooked
Alice: 也是这样吗
Alice: Is it the same?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes
Alice: 你不撒你不放盐吗
Alice: Aren't you going to add salt?
Alice: 哦你撒盐吗
Alice: Oh, are you adding salt?
Shure:  没撒
Shure: I didn't
Shure:  蘸酱油也行
Shure: Dipping it in soy sauce works too
Alice: 我们没酱油
Alice: We don't have soy sauce
Shure:  我们今天早上补给了
Shure: We restocked it this morning
Katrina: 昨天晚上小蛋糕都吃完了吗
Katrina: Did we finish all the cupcakes last night?
Alice: 没有还有点
Alice: No, there's still some left
Katrina: 放哪放冰箱了吗啊
Katrina: Where are they? Did you put them in the fridge?
Shure:  煎个蛋都这么费劲
Shure: Frying an egg is such a hassle
Katrina: 锅的问题
Katrina: It's the pan's fault
Katrina: 不是你们的问题
Katrina: Not your fault
Shure:  我不信了
Shure: I don't believe it
Alice: 现在几点
Alice: What time is it now?
Katrina: 这鸡翅也不能要了吧
Katrina: These chicken wings are probably not good anymore
Shure:  那边可以了是吗
Shure: Is that side done?
Alice: 我就已经放了很多油了
Alice: I already put a lot of oil
Alice: 这是炸蛋
Alice: This is a fried egg
Shure:  管他呢
Shure: Whatever
Shure:  多来点吧
Shure: Add more
Shure:  不行
Shure: No, don't
Alice: 我在这里放的油是我在家里放的两倍
Alice: The oil I used here is twice what I use at home
Shure:  我也是我我们家就其实不怎么吃油
Shure: Same here, we actually don't use much oil at home
Shure:  太大了
Shure: It's too big
Alice: 这个锅要是没太多油的话
Alice: If this pan doesn't have enough oil
Alice: 估计要
Alice: It will probably
Alice: 粘成成棉花糖
Alice: Stick like cotton candy
Shure:  连个好的蛋都煎不出来吗
Shure: Can't we even make a good egg?
Shure:  我不认可
Shure: I don't accept this
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Shure:  炸蛋
Shure: Fried egg
Alice: 还粘吗
Alice: Is it still sticking?
Shure:  （歌词）we are the champion my friend
Shure: (singing) we are the champion my friend
Alice: 吃一个煎蛋一天的油量已经够了
Alice: Eating one fried egg is enough oil for a day
Shure:  卧槽太不容易了
Shure: Damn, this is tough
Alice: 基本就是靠油把这个蛋跟铁隔开
Alice: Basically, the oil is keeping the egg from sticking to the pan
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yep
Alice:煎好再加下一个吗
Alice: Should we add the next one after this is done?
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  再补补钙
Shure: Need more calcium.
Shure:  完了这摊子太太大了
Shure: Oh no, this mess is too big.
Shure:  OK那个可以了
Shure: OK, that's good.
Shure:  那个可以拿出来
Shure: You can take it out now.
Shure:  完了完了
Shure: Oh no, oh no.
Alice: 拿筷子夹吧
Alice: Use chopsticks to pick it up.
Shure:  完美的煎蛋
Shure: Perfect fried egg.
Shure:  一起舞蹈没烦恼
Shure: Dance together, no worries.
Alice: 这么多油还在粘锅
Alice: So much oil and it's still sticking.
Alice: 家用的锅
Alice: It's a household pan.
Alice: 喷两下那个油壶就能煎出来
Alice: Just spray a bit of oil and it will fry perfectly.
Alice: 完美无缝的蛋
Alice: Perfect seamless egg.
Katrina: 啊啊
Katrina: Ah, ah.
Alice: 忍一下算了
Alice: Just bear with it.
Shure:  我只能说不忍直视
Shure: I can hardly watch.
Alice: 你那面包还煎不煎
Alice: Are you going to fry that bread or not?
Katrina: 哎我不用煎
Katrina: Oh, I don't need to fry it.
Katrina: 我直接吃就行
Katrina: I'll just eat it as is.
Shure:  塞两件衣服才就满了
Shure: Only two pieces of clothing and it's full.
Katrina: we are the
Shure:  你怎么还漏出来
Shure:  本来挺好
Shure:  我他妈恨不得弄死你
Alice: 来
Alice: 帮我把这个拿走
Alice: 过冷水
Shure:  用过冷水吗
Alice: 不用过冷水
Shure:  都行都行
Shure:  荷包蛋
Shure:  哎他们难道没用黄油吗
Katrina: 楼上有奶酪啊
Katrina: 刚买了奶酪
Shure:  用黄油煎面包香香
Katrina: 这可乐是昨天晚上开的是吧
Shure:  啊对做那什么的
Shure:  但是这黄油好难拆
Alice: 切一块嘿嘿
Shure:  来吧上刀
Shure: Come on, bring the knife.
Shure:  刀不在这一搁
Shure: The knife isn't placed here.
Shure:  你说的对
Shure: You're right.
Katrina: 这东西都放哪的呀这么大
Katrina: Where do you put this big thing?
Shure:  随便放里面
Shure: Just put it anywhere inside.
Katrina: 哎呀
Katrina: Oh no.
Alice: 你这衣服是要洗的吗
Alice: Are you going to wash these clothes?
Alice: 你没开啊
Alice: You haven't started yet.
Shure:  对对我等一会弄完了
Shure: Yeah, yeah, I'll do it in a bit.
Katrina: 我给你开了吧
Katrina: Let me start it for you.
Shure:  啊行
Shure: Ah, okay.
Shure:  你帮我倒点洗衣液然后开了就行
Shure: Just pour some detergent in and start it.
Katrina: we are shaking
Katrina: We are shaking.
Shure:  这面包忒油了
Shure: This bread is too oily.
Katrina: 呀什么东西
Katrina: Ah, what is this?
Shure:  哇好多蚂蚁啊
Shure: Wow, so many ants.
Katrina: 我去真的这边
Katrina: Oh my, really, over here.
Katrina: 这样放还能吃吗
Katrina: Can we still eat it like this?
Alice: 能吧
Alice: I think so.
Katrina: 有点害怕
Katrina: I'm a bit scared.
Katrina: 拿出来吧
Katrina: Let's take it out.
Katrina: we are shaking
Katrina: We are shaking.
Alice: 吃鸡蛋吗
Alice: Want some eggs?
Alice: 微微
Alice: Tasha.
Tasha: 生鸡蛋哦
Tasha: Raw eggs, huh?
Tasha: 哦哦水煮蛋
Tasha: Oh, boiled eggs.
Katrina: 呜呜
Katrina: Woo woo.
Katrina: 谁闹钟响了
Katrina: Whose alarm is ringing?
Tasha: 不是我
Tasha: Not mine.
Tasha: 嗯好像不响了
Tasha: Hmm, seems like it stopped.
Tasha: 鸡鸡蛋
Tasha: Chicken egg.
Shure:  这是
Shure: This is...
Shure:  面包片对
Shure: Bread slices, right.
Shure:  煎的面包片
Shure: Fried bread slices.
Shure:  杨老板呢
Shure: Where's Jake?
Tasha: 鲜牛奶应该可以吧
Tasha: Fresh milk should be fine, right?
Lucia: 牛奶在那边
Lucia: The milk is over there.
Tasha: 在哪边那呢
Tasha: Over there, huh?
Tasha: 哦那吗
Tasha: Oh, there?
Tasha: 这
Tasha: This.
Tasha: 哎另一个呢
Tasha: Hey, where's the other one?
Lucia: 你那个是用完了吗嗯
Lucia: Did you finish that one?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yep.
Katrina: 昨天又买新的吗
Katrina: Did you buy a new one yesterday?
Tasha: 另一瓶喝完了吗
Tasha: Did you finish the other bottle?
Katrina: 本来就上一次买两瓶
Katrina: I bought two last time.
Katrina: 一瓶已经喝完
Katrina: One's already finished.
Shure:  杨老板到尝尝面包吧
Shure: Jake, try some bread.
Shure:  杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Sure.
Jake: 先对个齐
Jake: Let's match them first.
Jake: 来
Jake: Come on.
Shure:  面包蘸番茄酱
Shure: Bread with ketchup.
Katrina: 嗯我手拧不开
Katrina: I can't open it.
Tasha: 还有人要喝牛奶吗
Tasha: Anyone else want milk?
Tasha: 好吧没有
Tasha: No? Okay.
Lucia: 我可以喝
Lucia: I can drink some.
Tasha: 算了我看到了
Tasha: Never mind, I see it.
Tasha: 你都已经背叛了
Tasha: You've already betrayed us.
Lucia: 等我把这这个橙汁不是柠檬汁喝完了
Lucia: Let me finish this orange juice, not lemon juice.
Lucia: 就喝
Lucia: Then I'll drink it.
Tasha: 黄油少切一点啊
Tasha: Cut a little less butter.
Katrina: 柠檬汁
Katrina: Lemon juice.
Tasha: 好没关系
Tasha: It's fine.
Tasha: 你就切吧
Tasha: Just cut it.
Tasha: 这么多可以
Tasha: This much is okay.
Shure:  哈哈放冰箱里
Shure: Haha, put it in the fridge.
Jake: 我吃哪一个呢
Jake: Which one should I eat?
Shure:  你尝个面包吧
Shure: Try some bread.
Shure:  那面包嘎嘎香
Shure: That bread is super tasty.
Tasha: 黄油就奶香奶香的了已经
Tasha: The butter is already so creamy.
Katrina: 扫吧
Katrina: Sweep it.
Shure:  是我碰到的吗
Shure: Did I bump into it?
Katrina: 不知道
Katrina: Don't know.
Tasha: 看摄像头
Tasha: Check the camera.
Jake: 回头看摄像头
Jake: We'll check the camera later.
Shure:  不是这必须调一下VCR我
Shure: No, we need to adjust the VCR.
Shure:  啊这窜下去了是吧
Shure: Ah, it slipped down, right?
Katrina: 嗯把杯子放在这上这会
Katrina: Yeah, put the cup here for now.
Jake: 正位数值扫一扫
Jake: Just scan the exact value.
Tasha: 天呐摔了几个
Tasha: Oh my, how many did you drop?
Shure:  不是他应该会掉到我的鞋里吧
Shure: Shouldn't it have fallen into my shoe?
Tasha: 啊你抖一抖
Tasha: Ah, shake it off.
Shure:  嗯我抖一抖
Shure: Okay, I'll shake it off.
Shure:  你把面包再给我
Shure: Hand me the bread again.
Shure:  我再煎一片面包
Shure: I'll fry another slice.
Katrina: 我们有扫帚吗
Katrina: Do we have a broom?
Tasha: 有煎一片还是两片
Tasha: Yes, fry one slice or two?
Tasha: 这么多黄油
Tasha: So much butter.
Tasha: 就煎一片
Tasha: Just one slice.
Tasha: 哦哦还有裹蛋糕液
Tasha: Oh oh, and coat it with cake batter.
Shure:  好吃吗这个还行吧
Shure: Is it tasty? It's okay, right?
Tasha: 好吃
Tasha: It's delicious.
Lucia: 特别香
Lucia: Smells amazing.
Shure: 其实你要想吃甜的再撒点糖
Shure: Actually, if you want it sweeter, you can sprinkle some sugar.
Shure:  嗯可以的
Shure: Yeah, that's fine.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm.
Katrina: 哎不好意思
Katrina: Oh, sorry.
Jake: 都是凶器啊
Jake: These are all deadly weapons.
Shure:  是啊就告诉AI这都是危险物品
Shure: Yeah, tell the AI these are all dangerous items.
Shure:  杨老板在新加坡自己给自己做吃的吗
Shure: Jake, do you cook for yourself in Singapore?
Jake: 不给开火
Jake: No, can't use the stove.
Jake: 屋里不给开火
Jake: Not allowed to use the stove indoors.
Shure:  从来没开过火是吗
Shure: You've never used the stove?
Jake: 屋里不给开火
Jake: Not allowed to use the stove indoors.
Jake: 就是就是
Jake: Just, just...
Jake: 没开过火
Jake: Never used it.
Jake: 确实没开过火
Jake: Really never used it.
Alice: 抖抖吧
Alice: Shake it off.
Alice: 你不得往下抖吗
Alice: Don't you need to shake it downward?
Alice: 你前面又出不去
Alice: It can't go out from the front.
Alice: 劝你穿个袜子
Alice: I advise you to wear socks.
Shure:  应该问题不大
Shure: It shouldn't be a big problem.
Shure:  没事
Shure: It's fine.
Jake: 你要不去检查一下
Jake: Maybe you should check it out.
Shure:  行我一会去厕所检查一下嗯
Shure: Okay, I'll check it out in the bathroom later.
Shure:  盘子端过来一下
Shure: Bring the plate over here.
Shure:  把这个拿着
Shure: Hold this.
Lucia: 用这煎蛋盘可以吗
Lucia: Can I use this pan for frying eggs?
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure:  煎蛋也可以吃
Shure: You can eat fried eggs too.
Shure:  但煎蛋没有没撒盐
Shure: But the fried eggs don't have any salt.
Lucia: 那就先用这盘盛一下吧
Lucia: Then let's use this plate for now.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Jake: 说什么啊哎
Jake: What are you talking about?
Lucia: 嗯可以先放过去了是吧
Lucia: Hmm, we can put it over there first, right?
Shure:  对放过去
Shure: Yes, put it there.
Tasha: AI拍了短片
Tasha: AI made a short video.
Jake: 哼OK
Jake: Hmph, okay.
Alice: 露西你帮我把它倒在这里面吧
Alice: Lucia, can you pour it in here for me?
Jake: 他是不是已经送来了
Jake: Has he already delivered it?
Jake: 你看看那边有没有啊
Jake: Can you check over there?
Lucia: 再套个袋子
Lucia: Let's put another bag over it.
Lucia: 要不咱垃圾袋在哪
Lucia: Or where are the trash bags?
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Alright.
Katrina: 我去
Katrina: I'll go.
Alice: 便签跟
Alice: Sticky notes and...
Shure: 零一袋面包去哪了
Shure: Where did the other bag of bread go?
Jake: 那后面也好你看看
Jake: It's also behind, check it out.
Katrina: 呃
Katrina: Uh...
Shure:  你有看到另一袋面包吗
Shure: Did you see the other bag of bread?
Katrina: 另一袋面包
Katrina: The other bag of bread?
Shure:  你要偷吃了我们不怪你的
Shure: If you secretly ate it, we won't blame you.
Shure:  你就哈哈
Shure: Just haha.
Katrina: 呵呵没有
Katrina: Haha, no.
Shure:  大方的说就好
Shure: Just say it openly.
Katrina: 我昨天放冰箱里呀
Katrina: I put it in the fridge yesterday.
Katrina: 都没有吗居然
Katrina: It's all gone, really?
Shure:  真没不是
Shure: Really not there?
Shure:  好奇怪丢了一袋面包
Shure: So strange, a bag of bread is missing.
Shure:  难受
Shure: So frustrating.
Shure:  对咱昨天没吃
Shure: We didn't eat it yesterday.
Shure:  而昨天生蚝忘吃了
Shure: And we forgot to eat the oysters yesterday.
Shure:  该补的忘补了
Shure: Forgot to make up for it.
Shure:  现在感觉整个人身体被掏空
Shure: Now I feel totally drained.
Jake: 廉价的快乐没有享受得到
Jake: Didn't get to enjoy cheap thrills.
Tasha: 今天来一个清蒸
Tasha: Let's have some steamed ones today.
Tasha: 清蒸生蚝
Tasha: Steamed oysters.
Tasha: 叫什么来着
Tasha: What's it called?
Tasha: 蒜蒜蒜蓉生蚝
Tasha: Garlic steamed oysters.
Lucia: 哦蒜蓉粉丝那种
Lucia: Oh, the garlic vermicelli type.
Jake: 那再蒸点
Jake: Then steam some more.
Jake: 再蒸三刀
Jake: Steam three more cuts.
Tasha: 有那个蒸笼呀
Tasha: We have that steamer.
Tasha: 很好蒸的
Tasha: It's easy to steam.
Jake: 得有得有
Jake: We have it, we have it.
Jake: 生蚝首先得有生蚝
Jake: First, we need oysters.
Tasha: 不是有吗
Tasha: Don't we have them?
Lucia: 昨晚是没放冰箱
Lucia: Last night, they weren't put in the fridge.
Jake: 对没放冰箱
Jake: Yeah, not in the fridge.
Jake: 化掉了没放冰箱
Jake: They thawed out, not in the fridge.
Shure:  没放冰箱就所以对
Shure: Not in the fridge, so yeah.
Tasha: 所以生蚝多少钱
Tasha: So, how much are the oysters?
Shure:  总共19块9吧
Shure: Total of 19.9 yuan, I think.
Shure:  得10只大概
Shure: About 10 pieces.
Shure:  还行吧
Shure: Not bad.
Katrina: 还行吧
Katrina: Not bad.
Jake: 其实是损失了多少个100新币
Jake: Actually, how many 100 SGD did we lose?
Jake: 有10个吧
Jake: About 10, right?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 我来看一下
Katrina: Let me check.
Jake: 报损了100新币的损失
Jake: Reported a loss of 100 SGD.
Tasha: 让我来打开订单看一下他到底多少钱
Tasha: Let me open the order to see exactly how much it was.
Shure:  不到4新币
Shure: Less than 4 SGD.
Jake: 但是损失了100
Jake: But we lost 100.
Katrina: 我想尝一小片
Katrina: I want to try a small piece.
Katrina: 你们谁想吃
Katrina: Who wants to eat?
Katrina: 就是我吃不完一整片
Katrina: I can't finish a whole piece.
Katrina: 那我直接撕喽
Katrina: I'll just tear it off.
Lucia: 直接撕吧没事
Lucia: Just tear it off, it's fine.
Tasha: 啊真的
Tasha: Really?
Tasha: 19块9一袋
Tasha: 19.9 yuan per bag.
Jake: 二楼也没有面包哈
Jake: There's no bread on the second floor either.
Shure:  对啊好奇怪啊
Shure: Yeah, it's so weird.
Shure:  就活生生就丢了
Shure: It just disappeared.
Tasha: 我们结账的时候结一袋还是两袋
Tasha: Did we check out with one or two bags?
Katrina: 两袋我觉得昨天购物车里的人
Katrina: Two bags, I think. Yesterday, the cart...
Tasha: 怎么会丢掉一袋面包
Tasha: How could we lose a bag of bread?
Katrina: 我记得
Katrina: I remember.
Lucia: 啊少了一袋吗
Lucia: Ah, are we missing a bag?
Lucia: 我昨天放那个蛋清液的时候
Lucia: Yesterday, when I put the egg white liquid
Lucia: 还是两袋呢
Lucia: There were still two bags
Tasha: 可是我记得昨天这个里面还有一袋啊
Tasha: But I remember there was still one bag in here yesterday
Katrina: 对我就两袋放冰箱了都
Katrina: Yeah, I put both bags in the fridge
Shure:  到底是谁偷吃
Shure: Who's been sneaking food?
Tasha: 在这呢
Tasha: It's right here
Lucia: 在这呢往这后面我这样
Lucia: It's right here, behind this, like this
Katrina: 看到了吗
Katrina: Can you see it?
Katrina: 呵呵呵原
Katrina: Haha, there it is
Shure:  原来你没偷吃啊
Shure: So you didn't sneak food after all
Katrina: 来你没偷吃嗯
Katrina: See, you didn't sneak food, huh?
Shure:  对不起是我污蔑你了
Shure: Sorry, I wronged you
Katrina: 我偷吃也不可能偷吃这个
Katrina: Even if I did sneak food, I wouldn't sneak this
Katrina: 我要偷吃我的冰淇淋
Katrina: If I were to sneak food, it'd be my ice cream
Katrina: 倒杯咖啡吧
Katrina: Let's make some coffee
Katrina: 狂摄入碳水
Katrina: Binge on carbs
Alice: 今天周几啊周五吗
Alice: What day is it today? Friday?
Katrina: 又要烧热水
Katrina: Gotta boil water again
Katrina: 热水壶啊
Katrina: The kettle
Shure:  你要找什么
Shure: What are you looking for?
Katrina: 水壶呢
Katrina: The kettle
Shure:  楼上吧
Shure: Probably upstairs
Katrina: 在这
Katrina: It's here
Jake: 这哪来的
Jake: Where did this come from?
Shure:  就是在冰箱里
Shure: It was in the fridge
Shure:  刚刚大家没找到
Shure: We just couldn't find it earlier
Jake: 这么有意思
Jake: How interesting
Shure:  藏在那个北冰洋后面呢
Shure: It was hidden behind the Arctic Ocean
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay
Katrina: 让一下
Katrina: Excuse me
Shure:  完美收官
Shure: Perfect ending
Lucia: 棒棒
Lucia: Awesome
Jake: 来插管
Jake: Time to insert the tube
Katrina: 嗯好的
Katrina: Okay
Alice: 我的线
Alice: My cord
Jake: 你线在这
Jake: Your cord is here
Jake: 不要着急限速
Jake: Don't rush, take it slow
Alice: 结束了吗
Alice: Is it over?
Katrina: 他没显示电量是没电
Katrina: It doesn't show power, is it dead?
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh
Katrina: OK
Jake: 有多少个
Jake: How many are there?
Shure:  太不容易了
Shure: It's so hard.
Shure:  我们又活过了一天
Shure: We made it through another day.
Shure:  就每天感觉把自己又养活一天
Shure: Every day feels like we're just surviving another day.
Shure:  非常有成就感
Shure: It's such an accomplishment.
Jake: 那个有那个生命条是吧
Jake: There's that health bar, right?
Shure:  什么生命条
Shure: What health bar?
Jake: 就是每个人头上一个生命条
Jake: Like everyone has a health bar above their head.
Jake: 刚起床的时候大概到到个20吧
Jake: When you just wake up, it's probably around 20.
Jake: 哦吃完了之后到几啊
Jake: Oh, and after you eat, what does it go up to?
Lucia: 吃一口
Lucia: Take a bite.
Jake: 都是赛博人
Jake: We're all cyborgs.
Jake: 吃了一口然后生命条就能加个5
Jake: You take a bite and your health bar goes up by 5.
Lucia: 哦噢我自己咬着
Lucia: Oh, I bit myself.
Katrina: 生命之减减呵呵呵
Katrina: Life reduction, haha.
Shure:  看着没没肉不行是吧
Shure: Can't do without meat, huh?
Shure:  要咬自己的
Shure: Have to bite yourself.
Jake: 准备插管
Jake: Prepare the tube.
Jake: 给你拿充电宝
Jake: I'll get you a power bank.
Lucia: 主要是您您做的这面包太好吃了
Lucia: Mainly because the bread you made is so delicious.
Katrina: 是怎么做
Katrina: How do you make it?
Katrina: 就是呃把那嗯嗯然后呢
Katrina: So, um, you take the... and then?
Shure:  然后裹上
Shure: Then wrap it.
Katrina: 嗯然后把那个面包裹上然后呢
Katrina: Yeah, then wrap the bread, and then?
Shure:  徐志瑶也太厉害了
Shure: Xu Zhiyao is amazing.
Shure:  然后最好拿黄油煎
Shure: And it's best to fry it with butter.
Katrina: 啊黄油直接倒进去然后
Katrina: Ah, just pour the butter directly in, and then?
Shure:  就是切下来一片然后放入锅
Shure: Just cut off a slice and put it in the pan.
Shure:  然后就可以化掉
Shure: Then it will melt.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Shure:  然后再把等它化掉之后
Shure: And then wait for it to melt.
Shure:  然后你把那个面包放进去
Shure: Then you put the bread in.
Jake: 歇着
Jake: Take a break.
Shure:  动手吧
Shure: Let's get to work.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Lucia: 我的血量就会在这一直递减
Lucia: My health will keep dropping.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 脑子学会了
Katrina: My brain learned that.
Jake: 得插管
Jake: Need to insert the tube.
Lucia: 在一直喝那个魔法药水
Lucia: She's been drinking that magic potion.
Shure:  什么魔法药水哦
Shure: What magic potion?
Jake: 她掉血了啊
Jake: She's losing health!
Lucia: 好疼啊哈哈哈
Lucia: It hurts so much, hahaha.
Katrina: 什么舌头
Katrina: What about the tongue?
Jake: 这叫中毒
Jake: This is called poisoning.
Jake: 中毒效应
Jake: Poisoning effect.
Tasha: 可见你对这个鸡蛋咬的有多重
Tasha: You must have bitten that egg pretty hard.
Lucia: 不是都好久没咬到自己舌头了
Lucia: I haven't bitten my tongue in so long.
Jake: 你把外头收拾收拾
Jake: Clean up outside.
Shure:  我的咖啡
Shure: My coffee...
Alice: 我的吗嗯
Alice: Oh my...
Alice: 这是我其中一个水杯
Alice: This is one of my cups.
Alice: 你没见过另一个
Alice: You haven't seen the other one.
Alice: 我另一个上面全是铁环
Alice: My other one is covered in rings.
Alice: 还是3D立体的
Alice: It's 3D and everything.
Alice: 哦这是我最简朴的水杯了
Alice: Oh, this is my simplest cup.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Alice: 花里胡哨的
Alice: It's so flashy.
Lucia: 说话有内涵
Lucia: Your words are so deep.
Jake: 哈哈这个怎么说
Jake: Haha, how do you say that?
Lucia: 哎我说咋这么吵呢
Lucia: Hey, why is it so noisy?
Alice: 关这个呢
Alice: Turn this off.
Alice: 咳嗡嗡的
Alice: It's buzzing.
Lucia: 让我看看我的京东
Lucia: Let me check my JD (Jingdong).
Alice: 你今天什么时候压花嘞
Alice: When are you pressing flowers today?
Katrina: 嗯随便都行
Katrina: Hmm, anytime is fine.
Katrina: 看看
Katrina: Let's see.
Alice: 感觉康乃馨比较坚挺
Alice: I feel like the carnations are pretty sturdy.
Lucia: 好这应该是我的
Lucia: Okay, this should be mine.
Lucia: 就想开了一个
Lucia: Just opened one.
Lucia: 其他的吧
Lucia: The others...
Katrina: 要把把那个
Katrina: You need to...
Lucia: 陆陆续续的想开
Lucia: Gradually want to open.
Katrina: 我看我之前
Katrina: I saw before...
Katrina: 你你那个罗霞
Katrina: Your, your thing, Rosia...
Katrina: 你那个水
Katrina: Your water...
Katrina: 水母灯是
Katrina: The jellyfish lamp...
Katrina: 就是也是要我们每个人都参与的吗
Katrina: Does everyone need to participate in it?
Lucia: 最好是我买的是那个串珠
Lucia: It's better if everyone does. I bought the beads.
Katrina: 6人份
Katrina: Six servings.
Lucia: 和那个叫什么欧根纱
Lucia: And that thing called organza.
Lucia: 然后6个人用他肯定够用
Lucia: It should be enough for 6 people.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm.
Lucia: 嗯但是现在就是
Lucia: But now...
Lucia: 因为我觉得材料包那个
Lucia: I think the material pack...
Lucia: 就是我之前做过
Lucia: I’ve used it before.
Lucia: 我觉得没有我刷到的那个教程好看
Lucia: I don’t think it looks as good as the tutorial I saw.
Lucia: 然后而且就是用就是废
Lucia: Plus, using waste bottles is more in line with our eco-friendly concept.
Lucia: 废瓶子做就更符合我们的环保理念
Lucia: But now I don’t know if we have 6 bottles.
Lucia: 但我现在不知道有没有6个瓶子
Lucia: Can we use bottles?
Lucia: 可以让我们做瓶子吗
Lucia: We need to find some.
Katrina: 要找找呀
Katrina: We need to look for them.
Lucia: 其实像这个瓶子就还可以我觉得
Lucia: Actually, this bottle can work, I think.
Lucia: 嗯这个对
Lucia: Yeah, this one.
Katrina: 嗯应该还有两
Katrina: Mm-hmm, there should be two more.
Lucia: 但是这个瓶子的话就太小了
Lucia: But this bottle is too small.
Lucia: 那天果粒橙那瓶还在吗
Lucia: Is that orange juice bottle still around?
Alice: 果粒橙应该扔掉了
Alice: The orange juice bottle was probably thrown away.
Alice: 嗯应该是从这里毕业了
Alice: Yeah, it probably graduated from here.
Lucia: 因为果粒橙那个他外面这个壳不光滑所以
Lucia: Because the orange juice bottle has a rough surface.
Tasha: 露西你要鸡蛋吗
Tasha: Lucia, do you want an egg?
Lucia: 煮鸡蛋吗
Lucia: Boiled egg?
Lucia: 嗯好
Lucia: Sure.
Lucia: 那我也来一个好了
Lucia: I’ll have one too.
Lucia: 其实我刚刚吃了一个煎蛋
Lucia: Actually, I just had a fried egg.
Katrina: 哎呦
Katrina: Oh wow.
Shure:  人家可以摄取两个
Shure: You can have two.
Tasha: 今天是全蛋宴是吗
Tasha: Is today an egg feast?
Tasha: 煮蛋蒸蛋煎蛋
Tasha: Boiled eggs, steamed eggs, fried eggs.
Shure:  不能不能辜负了护蛋使者的护蛋行动
Shure: We can't let the egg guardian's efforts go to waste.
Tasha: 什么护蛋使者
Tasha: What egg guardian?
Tasha: 孵蛋使者
Tasha: Egg incubator.
Lucia: 现在就看那个串珠和欧根纱
Lucia: Now we just have to wait for the beads and organza.
Lucia: 什么时候能到
Lucia: To arrive.
Alice: 早上水煮鸡蛋
Alice: Boiled eggs in the morning.
Alice: 中午
Alice: At noon...
Shure:  中午炒鸡蛋
Shure: Scrambled eggs at noon.
Alice: 晚上鸡蛋的妈
Alice: And egg mom in the evening.
Katrina: 吃鸡
Katrina: Eating chicken.
Katrina: Eating chicken
Lucia: 哎有人吃鸡吗
Lucia: Hey, is anyone eating chicken?
Katrina: 你这
Katrina: You...
Alice: 是和平精英吗
Alice: Are you talking about PUBG?
Alice: 很菜
Alice: So bad
Lucia: 其实我也好久没玩那个了
Lucia: Actually, I haven't played that for a long time
Shure: 下棋吧
Shure: Let's play chess
Tasha: 下棋下棋
Tasha: Let's play chess, let's play chess
Tasha: 打麻将的呢
Tasha: What about Mahjong?
Shure:  打麻将估计费点劲
Shure: Mahjong might be a bit challenging
Lucia: 但我今天发现
Lucia: But I found out today
Lucia: 我的收藏夹里的游戏今天打五折
Lucia: The games in my favorites are 50% off today
Lucia: 我要不要登录一下
Lucia: Should I log in?
Lucia: 先把它拿下来
Lucia: And grab them first
Alice: Steam吗你玩啥呀
Alice: On Steam? What are you playing?
Lucia: 最近在玩使命召唤
Lucia: Recently playing Call of Duty
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Alice: 这边那个麻将桌是本来就在那的吗
Alice: Was that Mahjong table always there?
Tasha: 很明显
Tasha: Obviously
Tasha: 是被他私藏进来的
Tasha: It was secretly brought in
Alice: 私藏进来的
Alice: Secretly brought in
Shure:  主要他
Shure: Mainly he...
Shure:  哎那就这样吧
Shure: Well, let's leave it at that
Lucia: 我觉得我的这个芍药还能再泡两天
Lucia: I think my peony can last another two days
Katrina: 但压花需要两三天
Katrina: But pressing flowers takes two or three days
Lucia: 但是他现在还没有开
Lucia: But it hasn't bloomed yet
Katrina: 没有一朵芍药开你可以
Katrina: Not a single peony has bloomed, you can...
Alice: 那你用康乃馨吧
Alice: Then use carnations
Alice: 你的康乃馨开的好盛大
Alice: Your carnations are blooming beautifully
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Mm
Lucia: 对我康乃馨好旺
Lucia: Yes, my carnations are thriving
Lucia: 但是芍药好自闭
Lucia: But the peonies are so closed off
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Mm
Katrina: 嗯我看我之前
Katrina: Mm, I see my previous ones...
Lucia: 我看我之前他还没想开
Lucia: From what I saw before, it still hasn't decided to bloom
Alice: 我的芍药已经开始谢了
Alice: My peonies have already started to wither
Jake: 他能催熟吗
Jake: Can it be forced to ripen?
Jake: 一天速成速开
Jake: Bloom in one day?
Lucia: 你以为这是期末考试啊
Lucia: Do you think this is a final exam?
Jake: 哈哈哈想让来他就开
Jake: Haha, if you want it to, it will bloom
Alice: 我想开了
Alice: I figured it out.
Lucia: 想开到一半就自闭了
Lucia: But you got halfway there and then shut down.
Katrina: 为啥呀熬夜可难受了
Katrina: Why? Staying up late is so uncomfortable.
Shure:  然后把那个什么弄完
Shure: Then finish that thing.
Shure:  这样就没有顾虑了
Shure: That way you won't have any worries.
Jake: 把那什么那什么呀
Jake: Finish what exactly?
Shure:  把我的毕设
Shure: My thesis.
Shure:  我的毕设报告
Shure: My thesis report.
Shure:  就剩最后那么一neinei
Shure: There's just that last little bit.
Jake: 好那你直播做毕设
Jake: Okay, then you can livestream your thesis work.
Katrina: 怎么真丑啊哈哈
Katrina: How ugly is that, haha.
Jake: 是压出来了吗
Jake: Was it pressed out?
Katrina: 哈哈哈怎么压的变干瘪了
Katrina: Haha, how did it get so shriveled?
Katrina: 我觉得
Katrina: I think...
Shure:  它压出了不一样的风格
Shure: It got pressed in a different style.
Jake: 烟花嗯
Jake: Fireworks, hmm.
Katrina: 嗯怎么跟跟网上的不太一样
Katrina: Hmm, why does it look different from the one online?
Jake: 网上长啥样
Jake: What does it look like online?
Katrina: 难道
Katrina: Maybe...
Katrina: 难道是要把他那个花瓣一个个剥下来
Katrina: Maybe you have to peel the petals off one by one.
Katrina: 然后那样子压吗
Katrina: Then press them that way?
Katrina: 然后如果整个压花的话
Katrina: If you press the whole flower...
Katrina: 他居然是这个样子
Katrina: It ends up like this.
Lucia: 这个是什么花啊
Lucia: What kind of flower is this?
Katrina: 我给你看当初的那一张图
Katrina: Let me show you the original picture.
Katrina: 他变成了那张
Katrina: It turned into this.
Katrina: 呵呵特搞笑啊
Katrina: Haha, it's so funny.
Katrina: 当初的图应该是
Katrina: The original picture should be...
Katrina: 这样
Katrina: Like this.
Katrina: 嗯康乃馨吧
Katrina: Hmm, it's a carnation, I think.
Jake: 花瓣大
Jake: The petals are big.
Lucia: 康乃馨
Lucia: A carnation.
Katrina: 就是直接这样子压的话
Katrina: If you just press it like this...
Katrina: 你看他会变成这样
Katrina: Look, it turns out like this.
Katrina: 要么就把它拆开
Katrina: Maybe you should take it apart.
Katrina: 就是把花瓣一个个剥开
Katrina: Just peel the petals off one by one.
Lucia: 我让我查查有没有什么攻略
Lucia: Let me check if there are any guides.
Katrina: 搜一下压花攻略了
Katrina: Search for flower pressing guides.
Jake: 可以研究研究
Jake: You can study it.
Tasha: 好无聊呀
Tasha: So boring.
Jake: 来压花
Jake: Come on, press the flower.